if you're a functioning highlevel
alcoholic practicing medicine don't stop
drinking Dr Mike says keep practicing
and just keep drinking not my words in
the Law and Order Universe the episodes
are judged by two separate yet equally
important influencers a doctor
influencer and a lawyer
influencer these are their
[Music]
opinions that's right you saw part one
on Dr Mike's Channel but now it's time
to talk about the legal repercussion
question of the very first episode of
Law and Order in the beginning of this
episode there's a doctor who gave a
medication that potentially ended
someone's life your daughter is dead and
he likely gave that medication under the
influence of alcohol so it's time to
prosecute boiler alert don't practice
medicine well under the influence of
alcohol failing to perceive a
substantial and unjustified risk that
might cause Suzanne Morton death
criminally negligent homicide
consciously disregarding that
substantial and unjustified risk man
slaughter too that is bang on why he
just listed off the different mental
States required for the two different
crimes failing to apprehend a
substantial unjustifiable risk knowing
that there is a substantial risk and
consciously disregarding it dang Ben
Stone absolutely nailed it there'll be
no prosecution if you testify against
auster and no job so so he actually did
engage in a conspiracy with the intent
to cover up yeah with the intent to
cover up he could be prosecuted unlike
the other doctors who were probably
complicit two or three times each month
he calls he says he's coming he's always
late because he's drunk wow you know
what they call those
rounds party round liver
rounds everyone knew why liver rounds
alcohol is metabolized by the liver I
guess they're doctors they have a
terrible sense of humor yeah true fair
suan Morton did have pneumonia and Dr
Oster did tell you the
lie I have flexible hours in my training
what the crap do you know how important
that is when you're raising a child
that's non-responsive doctor auster
didn't act drunk yeah okay so I guess
she covered up the crime is everyone
covering for him cuz he has something
hanging over everyone's heads in this
department I get I mean as they said
this doctor is a combination of Albert
schw and Albert Einstein so this is
amazing he never acted drunk but he was
drunk was he and he was always drunk on
Li
rounds giving it two medications that
have a bad interaction happens as
mistakes all the time in our healthare
system so the question is how does being
drunk impact your ability to make a
mistake if it drastically raises the
chance of you making a mistake and then
someone suffers does that become the
crime and you proved it is there any any
colorable reason why someone would
prescribe this kind of medication under
these circumstances no one gets opioids
her body aches when they're sick but
that's the only medicine he gave that
was problematic because the other
medicine she was already taking for her
mental health if he knew that that's the
crime but if the resident said Hey
doctor she's on it and he ignored him
because he's drunk that really goes to
criminal recklessness knowing and seeing
the unjustifiable risk ignoring it and
moving forward anyway
and he did tell you the LIE didn't he am
I going to lose my license this is
really really bad practice by the
district attorneys here they're
interviewing a witness alone if they
ever want to contradict what this
witness is saying they would have to
call themselves to the stand let's say
this this this doctor witness flips
flips and she's like no no he was
totally sober like well didn't you tell
me they're going to that he was totally
drunk she'll be like no I never said
that you got to have a police officer in
the room that says yeah I heard her
confess to the crime yeah just saved us
a lot of Sho
leather stiic versus austar in Ray the
death evangelist sik age
11 why is it that if it was drinking and
driving and then they harm someone it's
a closed case but a doctor doing it it's
not because there are specific laws that
deal with drinking and driving because
it's so problem so there is no law that
says you can't practice while drunk
probably not it would be a more
generalized rule like Reckless homicide
wow you said if you're educated on the
risks of drinking W under the influence
and then you do it again after that
you're knowledgeable and they can prove
that now so they add more charges can't
you then say because this is an expert
of the human body this doctor that they
should know that drinking and practicing
medicine is even worse than a regular
person 100% and that is a huge problem
with the defense that they're creating
they're saying like this is the greatest
doctor that's ever lived well then he
should really know it's bad to practice
well
intoxicated a better uh strategy would
be this guy's a terrible doctor it's not
cuz he's drunk it's because he's a
terrible doctor you objected to the
administration of madine I suggested
esenin but Dr AER grew angry he said if
I didn't like the way the hospital was
being run that I should continue my
training elsewhere that doctor would
make a terrible terrible witness because
he lied to the police and tried to cover
up the mistake
uh I would destroy that guy on
Cross do you know how long Dr AER has
been practicing medicine Dr Risa
objection relevance speculation um I
don't know uh 25 years
maybe and do you know where he went to
medical school he's really asking a
bunch of questions from this witness
that this witness shouldn't really know
the answer to you don't have to ask
every doctor that worked with exactly do
you know my client went to
Harvard Harvard I believe that's
correct that's how long have you been a
doctor 2 Years sir I see and where did
you go to medical
school at the University of
bisha thank you that is one of the least
effective cross-examinations does that
ever seen they're not challenging
whether or not you gave the right
medicine they're challenging the fact
that you were drunk while practicing
medicine Dr Mills were you present on
March 15th when Suzanne Morton was
admitted yes and what was your reaction
when Dr auster prepared to inject
Suzanne Morton with
madine I said her chart showed she was
taking phenelzine but paradine was
contraindicated there's a there's a lot
here that the defense attorney could
absolutely go after uh number one she
lied and covered it up and in a way that
probably could be twisted to make it
seem like this was a possible okay thing
to prescribe and the jury isn't going to
necessarily know that this is a horrible
narcotic isn't it true that you had to
run a second toxical screen to even find
madine and fenine in Suzanne Morton's
body that's because both drugs are
unusual unto themselves thank you doctor
and would not be found unless
specifically requested thank you Doctor
which they were there are there are much
better strategies for getting a witness
to stop their answer and and none of
them are just saying thank you thank you
doctor thank you doctor mainly You' want
to talk to the judge and say your honor
I object this is non-responsive I asked
a yes or no question you're training the
witness to to stop speaking after
they've given you the answer that you
want the fact that they had to run a
second test has nothing to do with the
situation yeah the fact that they had to
run a second test was because the first
test didn't include those medications So
my answer to that would be no I didn't
have to run a second test I had to run
the first test for those medications
yeah isn't it possible that pneumonia
killed Suzanne Morton no
oh it's possible that Death raay From
Mars killed her what
nonresponsive yeah I mean so some people
do ask similar questions in real life
and you get answers like that but more
likely what's going to happen is
immediately the first redirect question
by the district attorney is so you said
it was possible how How likely is that
you're you're teeing up the district's
attorney to absolutely Crush you Dr AER
must have spoken to you during the
course of the party every 5 minutes fill
her up was his speech slurred not so I
remember did he seem drunk in any way I
never saw anyone hold his liquor better
oh ooh o that's a little bit of a
problem yeah this guy was drinking like
a fish but boy he was uh metabolizing it
quite well I
guess during our years of research into
alcoholism Dr Walt
have you ever observed people who appear
to be sober but are in fact drunk it
happens all the time it could happen to
Dr auster objection it could happen to
my aunt Minnie but it
doesn't oh my God that is not how you
make an OB that made me giggle though
that was pretty good I don't know he
looks very likable here yikes I mean if
you're going to do nonsense like that to
Pander to the jury you got to say you
know objection relevance you have to
have some grounds for the objection you
can't just say objection my aunt Minnie
my aunt Minnie objection Aunt Minnie
I'll rephrase the
question if a 55y old
man
weighing 185 lbs having consumed 10
shots of bourbon in 2 hours appears to
be Stone Cold
Sober does that mean he is in fact in
full possession of his
faculties no which is what we just
talked about I yeah I'm I'm glad that we
finally have an expert here because you
are allowed to pose hypotheticals to an
expert now if that same 55-year-old man
weighing 185 lb has several drinks and
he appears to be quite sober and makes a
mistake would that mistake necessarily
be caused by his drinking or might he
have made that mistake
anyway obviously that's impossible to
say you'd have to be that 55-year-old
man to know well I mean even that's a
really terrible way of putting it even
that 55-year old man wouldn't
necessarily know one way or the other
you know I mean you would have to be in
their mind to know where did you spend
the week of June 10th Mr Hoffman in
Maine fishing oh was Edward auster with
you
no did he ask you to tell people that he
had been with you on that
trip yes I just find it amazing that
this guy asked like a dozen people to
lie for him yeah and they all said yeah
absolutely you know like yeah we know
that girl died in the ER just a little
while ago we're totally cool with
covering up all your crimes yeah and why
was that Mr
hofman he didn't want anyone to know
where he was he checked himself into a
clinic
ah the cson clinic okay he knows he has
a drink problem and he doesn't want
anyone else to know he has a drinking
problem that is consciousness of guilt
and consciousness of a substantial risk
yeah super bad news for the doctor Y
what kind of Clinic is the Coulson
Clinic Mr Hoffman rehab I
assume it's a substance abuse Clinic
there you
go thank you how long is your treatment
program lasts 28
days how long did Dr OST stay six days
he left against our advice would you say
that Dr AER knew he was an alcoholic by
the time he
left oh he would never have come in the
first place if he hadn't I have no
further questions are you
positive you now did Dr auster say to
you I am an alcoholic oh good question
oh in fact didn't Dr AER say to you I am
am not an
alcoholic you must have this yes or no
Dr asmus please did he say I am not an
alcoholic yes the redirect is going to
be crushing first of all have other
alcoholics come to you and said they
were not an alcoholic yeah in fact the
first step is admitting you're an
alcoholic because alcoholics don't like
to admit that they're
alcoholics did Dr aus discuss his
drinking with you anything that
transpired between Dr Oster and myself
is protected by patient doctor
privilege but as well as patient and
Doctor your friends we
are where did you have lunch with him on
June 7th in your office no at the four
seasons did you conduct your physical
examination of Dr auster
there I no I I I told
him that
um if he didn't stop drinking he'd be
dead in 5
years how do they know he said that
that's just that's just Dick Wolf
writing the defense calls Dr Edward
auster he's dropping his Amendment what
is the amendment the the Fifth Amendment
so the tragic death of a six-year-old
led to sight for one child and a new
heart for another oh the boy who got the
heart is now the star shortstop of the
Little League basball
team and finally how many how many Bo he
testifying how good of a doctor he is no
he's testifying that because this girl
died other patients got organs what the
hell does that have to do with anything
hold on I like I really like the look
that that guy in the jury gave just like
oh boy oh Mr
Stone yeah hour was almost up could you
hold your cross-examination until after
lunch of course your honor oh my oh wow
uh that's bad that feels bad no no they
get the entire lunchtime to prepare
their cross- examination if you get that
time you are taking that time and
medically speaking judges who recently
ate will give lighter
sentences if you're tried just after
lunch yeah that is true
that
money drinking to have you had a drink
today objection your honor relevancy
what that's you're allowed right yeah
that would be absolutely admissible yeah
your state of mind and your ability to
practice medicine while being
intoxicated 100% relevant like oh boy
yes more than one
yes
yes how many more than
one so I lost count of 49 I mean any
answer that he gives is bad he could lie
and say the incorrect number in which
case it's like oh wow he can't even
remember how many he had um or he could
be honest and say I could I had X number
this is a a a potentially very dangerous
cross-examination because we've now
establish that he's been drinking a lot
during lunch M but if he's able to have
all of his mental
faculties then you've kind of shown that
you weren't criminally
Reckless I'm not sure I mean that's bad
test do you recall was it between two
and five drinks I don't
recall doctor is it not a fact that you
had six Bourbons on the rocks at chances
Pub not 45 minutes ago objection you're
I'll allow it what ground let's move on
Mr
Stone oh my God we yeah no this is first
of all I'll allow it and let's move on
are two contradictory statements by the
judge if if I was the district attorney
here I really would have milked these
questions for more because he really
went for the ultimate question but he
could have said is it possible that you
had as many as six Bourbons you know out
of everything his inability to remember
how many drinks he had really goes I
think to the mental faculties and being
able to practice medicine would you step
into the well Dr AER objection your
honor there's no need for Dr AER to
stand
side there's no need wait is he going to
do a sobriety test
yeah what's going on Mr Stone does Dr
AER look drunk to he your own what the
hell is that supposed to do I must be
allowed to show Dr uster is in the
courtroom and he's drunk they honor I
strenuously objec no he's strenuously
obje is that is that are there levels to
objections is was the highest yeah
that's not a thing that is I mean and a
few years later Aaron sorin would use
that I strenuously object in A Few Good
Men your honored the defense strenuously
objects and requests an 802 conference
so that his honor might have an
opportunity to hear discussion oh wow
strenuously objec and I should take some
time to reconsider including the judge
and they would spend like the next 10
minutes making fun of Dei Moore for
saying I strenuously object that's it's
so oh my God proceed Mr
Stone finally the judge doctor and the
defense attorney and then the guy gets
up the defense attorney made zero
objections uh valid OB this is the New
York City Police Department manual I'm
going to administer a standard test you
can't to determine whether a person is
operating a motor vehicle he's
testifying he's like he's explaining
what he has in his hand can he say that
to the person to the witness not I mean
do you recognize this this is the I
guess I mean I guess you could ask do
you recognize this but there's no reason
he would what you do is you make him
perform the test hold the book then you
call like a a police officer explain
what this book is yeah explain what I
just did yeah and you were in court when
I admitted or I administered this test
did I administer this test correctly did
this guy fail this test yeah that that's
how you would do it under the influence
this is an outrage there you go as Mr
Stone instructs your doctor take the the
fifth
buddy now something like this actually
did happen in court not this in
particular but in a very famous case the
OJ Simpson case with the glove with the
glove he was asked to wear the glove I
think he probably could have taken the
fifth and refused to do it there's
speculation that once he knew he was
going to be doing that he basically did
like hand curls for like two weeks I
mean the craziest thing is that he was
wearing a latex glove so as not to
contaminate the the the leather glove
and so between him probably bulking up
his hand wearing a latex glove what I
didn't know any of this is this known
well yeah yeah it happened on TV free
right now yeah raise your arm to the
level of your shoulder close your eyes
and point your nose with your index
finger missed
he didn't even try to correct it he
didn't even
go nailed it there's something to be
said about someone who is drinking that
much every day if they were to stop
there's a risk of developing something
known as DTS delirium tremin where they
can actually have seizures uh violent
actual
Tremors um psychiatric breaks because
they're not consuming alcohol as part of
their withdrawal
withdrawal from alcohol is one of the
worst withdrawals maybe on the same
level as opioids so like those are the
two most uh withdraw prone medications
yeah so you heard it here if you're a
functioning high level alcoholic
practicing medicine don't stop drinking
Dr Mike says keep practicing and just
keep drinking not my words coming from
the lawyer himself it's your your
testimony you're the one that's under
Earth all right now it's time for the
grading
Dr Mike what kind of medical grade does
this show get Medico ethically I would
give this an F because you shouldn't
practice medicine under the influence
but medical accuracy I'd give it a B
minus had the chest compressions been a
little bit better I would have given it
a higher grade so not bad similarly
legally speaking a lot of accuracy they
got the mental states of different kinds
of homicides right incredible uh there
were some courtroom Shenanigans but I
got to say B+ great episode of Law and
Order so if you haven't seen it go see
part one on Dr Mike's Channel and until
next time we'll see you in court and
I'll stay where you stay happy and
healthy out of court out of not in court
out of court now Dr Mike and I had a ton
of fun shooting this we actually spent
hours watching and riffing on each other
and his dog bear made many unscheduled
appearances but not all that footage
could make its way into the YouTube
version which is why my fellow creators
and I created nebula today's sponsor
there you can find the extended version
of this video this basically twice as
long I put all of my videos up there
early and AD free and I'm not only on
nebula but I'm a co-owner because nebula
is a streaming platform built for
creators buy creators and for the
holidays they're doing something
completely wild nebula is offering until
the end of the month a lifetime
membership instead of a subscription
it's a onetime payment that will get you
everything nebula offers forever and I
know tens of thousands of you signed up
for nebula using the Curiosity stream
bundle but unfortunately that's ending
curiosity stream has informed us and
even included in their latest SEC filing
that they don't intend to pay us bundle
Revenue in 2024 this means that I won't
get any money from the bundle
subscription so the bundle is breaking
and you're not going to be able to have
access to nebula anymore after 2024
maybe I'll make a video about that in
the future but if you'd like to support
me the only way to ensure that the money
you spend on nebula goes to me is to
sign up directly so no nebula is not
going bankrupt on the contrary it's more
successful than it's ever been but we're
offering lifetime memberships for a
select few fans so that we can make even
more original content huge Productions
from your favorite creators and we're in
it for the long haul like lifetime
memberships allow us to not take on
outside investors it's the opposite of a
going out of business sale it's a going
into bigger business sale and if you're
new here what nebula offers includes
tons of exclusive videos from me
original series from your favorite
people movies plays classes and more
with your favorites like Johnny Harris
Neo jetlag real engineering real life
lore and legal eagle we create the
content that other people react to and
you can see my featurelength documentary
bad law words good uh other nebul
exclusive content including my full
length interview with the screenwriter
of my cousin Vinnie and my not fors sa
video about lawsuits too hot for YouTube
but like I said until the end of the
month you can get an exclusive lifetime
membership it's $300 for life no tricks
no gimmicks that's it forever and if
that's not your speed that's completely
fine you can still get a 40% discount on
a yearly membership that pencils out to
less than $3 per month and if you want
to pay monthly that's fine too we have
that option so click on the link that's
on screen right now or down below to get
your lifetime membership right now or a
huge 40% discount on yearly just click
right now down below before that deal
goes away and after that click on this
link over here for more legal eagle or
I'll see you in court